what up people we are gonna watch today
brooklyn nine nine two by five yeah you
know the drill all i ask that you hit
that like button if you wanna watch the
full length watcher logs or you sync up
with the time code those over at our
patreon page cover a whole bunch of
shows over there prepper whoever it is
now thank you appreciate it very much
let's
do this
why are you sitting at my desk
lieutenant miller from internal affairs
is here he's taken over my office
apparently someone has been leaking
classified information to a criminal
syndicate the entire squad is under
investigation what no one hears a mole
how can you be so sure because i know
these guys i know everything about them
watch this i know what everyone's going
to do tonight it's thursday so gina is
going to leave early to rehearse with
her new dance group dancy ray
amy's going to be going over her weekly
budget and charles will be attending a
pizza for one cooking class tonight's
menu pepper oloney
if i run and leap at terry he will most
certainly catch me in his arms coming in
holding coffee
i'm sorry handshakes are the greatest
avenues of germ transmission i generally
prefer simple nods
have you ever taken confidential
information about an ongoing
investigation out of this precinct no
i would never do something that stupid i
did something really stupid i need your
help
i also maybe sometimes bring home case
files to work on them after hours and i
might not be that great about returning
them
are you aroused because of what a bad
boy i am no no
[Laughter]
what brings you here i heard you were
under investigation by internal affairs
didn't want to miss that so much time
with your ear to the pavement it's a
pity a truck hasn't run over your head
i'm looking for detective scully you
must be from iab i'm deputy chief once
nice to meet you
iab exists outside of department
hierarchy i don't answer to you
detective scully you're up pope oh okay
um no
you know we'll do this over the phone
[Laughter]
detective diaz can you give me even a
shred of good news about your drug task
force the good news is i can be brief
about it we have nothing
[Laughter]
task force has made some busts
but we still haven't found any
high-level dealers or major drug stashes
but we will soon is that a promise or
just another lollipop that no one's ever
gonna lick jesus christ
i felt that one
sarge and i are going undercover at
electric library it's a silent dish
everyone wears headphones it's actually
very respectful to the neighbors except
for the lewd accent vomiting
so hopefully we'll buy some giggle pig
great i hope there's a lot of drug
activity there
one box of files and one box of powdered
donuts from under my bed oh cool can i
see those yeah sure okay
whoa no no no oh this is a new car i
won't have you jake it up with donut
powder oh
i hate to say it but we still need to
make one more stop there's still some
files at my old place aka gina's
apartment fine i'll call her
wow there's so many fancy buttons on
your steering wheel it's like a spy car
that's cool product placement car
call jeanalin eddie
what is that voice it's my spy voice car
initiate ghost mode it's a nicholas cage
voice yeah
i do have some good news in three
two
pocket donuts
well luckily i still have a key from
when i lived here
here we go
boyle
oh no
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
how long has this been going on we
hooked up once last summer and then the
nightmare started again about a month
ago ever since then it's been orgasm
city
oh
gross right guys wait a minute
there was no pizza for one cooking class
tonight you've been lying to me for
weeks people can't surprise you it's me
candles ooh sorry i'm going to a
prenatal yoga class
don't be mad jake you still know me i'm
still charles i just have four extra sex
moves five forgot about boy on top ugh
[Music]
[Laughter]
they are weird yeah
this is not a disco and i should know i
was raised on disco
[Music]
oh
yeah
my daughters go to the learning grove
did you get that from a vintage store or
something no i went there i was in the
dolphins class and you don't do drugs or
drink have a water on the house huh
i learned that my babies are on the
right track because their preschool
turns out nice kids yeah i can't wait to
tell holt that at the task force meeting
now let's go look for some bad kids who
went to subpar preschools
right if we sit
is everything okay
nothing's
okay once
circling me like a shark frenzied by
chum
[Laughter]
i am buffeted by the winds of my
and cast about by the towering waves of
cruel fate
i've worked the better part of my years
on earth overcoming every prejudice
oh yes
and now i feel it being ripped from my
grasp and with it the very essence of
what defines me as a man
and you ask
is everything okay
you take care of amy but how to make it
look like an accident i'm not saying
murder just talk to her like a normal
person right even better get her to tell
me all her little secrets then
[Music]
hello no
i took these files home a while ago even
though i shouldn't have and now i'm
bringing them back isn't that funny are
you laughing behind the mask
[Music]
oh god
kev jake it's after midnight this had
better be about a murder no i wish look
i'm really sorry but i have to talk to
captain holt raymond your work life is
here
miller is sure there's a mole in the
precinct and the only way to prove it's
not me is to figure out who it is you
said there wasn't a mole you said you
knew everything about these people well
it turns out i don't
i've learned some truly horrible things
tonight
oh no
goodness
boyle is sleeping with gina
[Laughter]
boyle is your most trusted friend so he
has to be involved your use of the word
horrible leads me to believe that the
matter was sexual in nature given your
obvious immaturity
of course you would be most upset if
boyle would have slept with someone you
knew from your childhood thus the song
gina that was amazing coming to my study
let's figure out who that mole is
let's go through the squad one by one
rosa is very secretive i don't know
anything about her personal life charles
has expensive tastes gina has said many
times that she would sell us all out for
five minutes with blake griffin
twins to private school but on his
salary that's difficult
plus with twins one of them's always
evil
so
it's cagney
it's over between me and charles i'm so
upset
amy when will i ever find a relationship
as perfect as the one you have with
freddy it's teddy
i hate that guy
what else what else what else
wait a minute crazy peaches i saw rosa
used watermelon but then when i asked
her about it she said she had never
eaten that or any other kind of melon
now that i say it out loud it doesn't
seem like much no put it on the board
so tired i can't keep my eyes open
here i need you to slap me i'm not going
to do that berlin
oh i thought perhaps the element of
surprise
you spent six months undercover in the
mafia and of many criminal contacts
you've been known to flaunt departmental
rules and regulations and you are deeply
in debt well
if you hadn't tricked me into getting
car insurance
because i heard you call deputy chief
once by her first name and after that
you told her you hoped she got carried
off by crows that is gross
insubordination madeleine is irrelevant
our battles extend beyond the confines
of white rules
how come you didn't know there was a
mole in your precinct that's right
because you did because you are the mole
you mole i've heard enough
please return your guess pajamas guest
it's toothbrush for you to be suspended
[Music]
too far
peralta should you be suspended by now
yes and i know that you're mad that i'm
here but you're about to get over it
because i know who the mole is
lieutenant miller
i think he's spying for once once you
said it yourself your battles extend
beyond the confines of nypd rules she
wants information about your task force
but she can't get access so she sent in
a spy
that's why miller was skulking around
the file room when i was supposed to be
the only skulker that's interesting i
did notice something odd when he and
once first met
she just nodded at him she didn't even
try to shake his hand
oh i thought she just knew not to shake
his hand
we don't have any hard proof that
they're working together well
lucky for you proof is my middle name
and yours is jared
juice box
jellyfish
jamiroquai yes
i want to play ball clear my name and
i'll give you information about captain
holt wow i'm interested what kind of
information
it's all on this
pretty dope drive right
okay i could get in a lot of trouble for
this but the big secret about captain
holt is
that i have a flare for the dramatic
look behind me
we're actually in front of you that's my
fault i thought the layout was gonna be
different didn't know how you guys were
gonna be sitting i took a chance
fine you're right but you can't prove
that it's just your word against mine
ooh actually it's your word against you
i put a recording device in this dope
drive so i got your whole conversation
you were going to leave my precinct and
my task force alone nice
you were
once me
you should never worry about your kids
you're the best dad i know
cagney and lace are going to grow up
great you think so 100
you're right
they're going to be twin presidents
one person to trick everyone
excuse me i have an announcement to make
can i have everyone's attention please
oh god oh charles boyle and i had sex
what the hell gina first off i would
like to remind you all about several
notable men from my past the rock
climbing backpacker the underwear model
the guy who looked like tywin lannister
good call
how many times did you do it 16 and a
third don't ask can't explain i have a
question
do you have any regrets
no
oh it was pretty fun oh
hey
i should have said this last night but
your first casual relationship nice work
i know i didn't even propose her once
just like i know everyone here yes you
do although there is something you
didn't know about me my middle name
is jacob
[Music]
[Laughter]
well done
[Laughter]
my middle name is jake peralta
oh yeah that was kind of an intense
episode right
a little bit more on the beat and a
little less on the laps even though
there were many laughs they're
suspenseful you can feel the
you feel the drama what was going on
with holt there he seemed like he was
really on edge yeah he was on fire i was
like you're kind of a dick man
your competitive side yeah brings out
the worst in you sometimes yeah and i
did have my mind going too of like ah
that wouldn't make anyone of the main
castle mold would they they can't but
it'd be kind of a cop-out if it was just
some other person in the priesthood we
never met before that wouldn't be any
fun when he named him at first i i
forgot what the guy's name was i thought
they were gonna do that
yeah yeah i would have been disappointed
with that but the the wave
but like yeah there was like dramatic
flare in here like that
this was like a
a classic case of tension and release i
thought for this particular episode the
way they had
uh even discovering like gina and boyle
sleeping together the way they handled
the moment at the end where she's
you know proclaiming it to the precinct
of hey i actually did this uh taking
ownership of it
um
i was surprisingly uh
surprisingly a little taught in the way
how everything was going down here yeah
even like when they're teaming up and
they're ready to try to figure out who
the mole is you feel the ticking time
clock of like jake only has a few hours
left it's already before he gets
suspended again and uh i i thought it
was actually pretty impressive how it
all went down because i did notice she
didn't shake his hand
but i thought like oh she just
knows
better
yeah like she's just
a solid mislead for that reason yeah i
didn't i didn't look into it as a clue
yeah
but you caught it's dizzy that's the
good detective brain on you or it's
really just a good good show to make you
note that yeah
yeah good visual story because it drew a
lot of attention to the fact that you
wouldn't shake jake's hand so then to
have that moment there i thought like oh
she might have just known this about him
yeah and so that's what makes her like
conniving and clever because she and she
knows who she's dealing with so i was
surprised but even like yeah the way
they amplified uh
the the gravitas here at times actually
didn't even read as funny but genuinely
like a little yeah you actually get
caught up in it yeah they're gonna whole
thing this whole monologue in the bar
when he's talking with like it's it's
funny because of how serious they're
taking it but at times you're like that
is a real serious speech he's given
right here that was chef's chef's kiss
in the writing and the delivery and i
mean he especially like everybody i
thought was on was on firing on all
cylinders is the phrase i'm looking for
across this episode but yeah andre
brauer was like on another plane
throughout this like i i do love what
that does to his character because it
seems like anything that threatens his
hard-won authority and anything that has
to do with once really you know brings
out this spirit within him that yeah it
can be quite haphazard in in application
but also just makes for some of the most
fun to watch performances
and yeah this this was an episode where
yeah i think in doing that and letting
some of the plot lines breathe a little
better it's like it felt like it felt
like we did a lot you know it felt like
a very substantial episode even though
it's still only like 21 minutes or
whatever well they had boyle and gina
they had jake and amy and they had jake
and holtz they had
rosa and terry
um
which was uh the one that made the least
the the least impact of an impression
that was more just the funny one but i
liked how
i did it it sounded that was it was very
funny consistently hilarious i've never
been to an inside like uh dis uh silent
disco but i've seen them on like santa
monica beach and stuff and i
participated in them before
where you're like outside and it and it
is kind of funny to look at but i
imagine inside is just visually really
funny auditory-wise it's funny too yeah
um clues you into
what's kind of whimsical and funny about
dance
yeah but i like how this this this the
person they ended up arresting was uh
uh representation for terry and his
father-daughter dilemmas that he's
always caught in between here yeah
absolutely oh yeah i was pleasantly
surprised by this still rooted in the
characters even if it wasn't yet the
most impactful plot one i thought this
one had uh it wasn't like dramatic but
it had a bit more of a that that comedy
like those comedy movies that have a bit
of an intensity to it which makes them
which makes the comedy funnier because
they take the serious they're not
undercutting a little bit more serious
moments they just like sprinkled in
throughout like there's not one scene
here that's just full-on drama but the
discovery of certain
aspects are like oh like i found myself
kind of ripped by the immediacy of the
plot and not really
thinking about like hey i'm not really
laughing right now you know yeah
yeah yeah and nor was it really focusing
on having like a heart it was just it
was like this this this is an intense
situation and you can feel the clock
yeah so yeah kudos to that man that was
i was impressed with that one i was
really impressed with that one yeah
absolutely all right guys well leave
your thoughts down below subscribe click
that bell hit that like button and hey
it's the end of the month so let's shout
out some patrons
levitate odell josh barnes burner long
dong shondon oscar golden globes
bro
[Laughter]
lauren american horse of course of
course there's the joke i'm simply faded
peter pacheco
meet me in joanna's st louis
my that could have been better
matthew mark luke and john men sing
roe cree a star wars story some jew 94.
taylor made for me
that lusting busting justin martin
rosie's not nosy my baby lady groovy
ruby dynamite is so tired
guess who i'm calling oh it's it's it's
calling yes it's calling calling philip
j smith jr let's say jen smith's on the
other line
melanie leblanca versus eonda
natalie flev doran patreon inside jokes
chase gardner the leaf blower ava
drazdakova doesn't live in moldova i i i
don't i don't think you do now his name
is summer hottie wow that is very
self-flattering especially in the fall
oh i need to cool down a little bit as
you're bringing the heat back oh man
with your hot summer
vibe
vibrations anyway thank you to everyone
especially sj94
for being here today you guys rock
[Music]
you